welcome to this video playing shock Matt
probably means checkmate in Norwegian
let me speculate that okay going for a
four against the Queens gambit accepted
a line that I really think is good but I
never managed to study it in any detail
i thinkI 565 is a mafia yeah I'm
completely in pletely forgot things I
think d5 is interesting
still forgot things I think you can take
f3 and 95 95 that looks that looks weird
to put it mildly Queenie for all right
check if that's not right something's
really wrong with chess so 95 now right
95 I can I just take that on b5 I might
have night see form okay maybe I must
maybe I need to start with de and then
95 let's start with that
96 95
beach be takes of course also 95 and I'm
threatening to take on b7 was check and
c7 check and what not we are taking on
b7 mostly you cannot take a 3 let's say
don't don't really see what movie is
going to play now 90 x 95 quindi one
check but that's not going to help him
very much check yeah and wonder Bishop
t2 is also possible g4s still hanging
it's a double attack c6 ng form
Knight a5 was a very very strange
decision yeah maybe a move like that
with you for hanging him
hey I shoulda played 93 right that might
might maybe that was better this is
still looking a bit unclear really funny
funny funny funny 96 96 takes on e4 and
ce4 hangs with check sometimes can you
believe that taking on g4 he will take
c4 amazing
now we're looking at simple in here
maybe Knight g4 he really has Quincy
form
hmm why not Knight c3 and he resigns
amazing and that really isn't clear this
this weird bit position our head is
clear I don't see a movie at the moment
that I can play I don't see a player
will move
unreal unreal really unreal amazing
really amazing so this says something I
can do here 93 maybe still cannot take
you to the spin
amazing this game is still going on we
are them I should have played 93 simply
set up bishop t2 really remarkable I am
i winning a piece now maybe maybe still
and down to one minute ten
b5 I have check on a six so I don't need
to play Queen B 5 or something
and I thankfully is taking some time so
and that i'm not exactly behind on the
clock and Queen B 5 is a threat now
time warning check black resigned well
I'm glad to have one that at the end
though it was certainly badly played
them okay so let's have a look at that
and I takes the other comp okay it gives
95 ultimately but not as a win okay 11
pawn the defense however is cool
computer wants to play Bishop d1 I was
thinking of this Jackie but this is not
working of course I can change here and
here and then this is still hanging but
he could have played this one which
would have come as quite a shock then I
have to play be three crazy 97 yeah and
that is not know I know what that is the
comps s plus 1 but it's not a very clear
position in a way okay so Bishop b5 was
a good solution that is that's a that's
a bit simpler he lost time with this
Knight a5 and stuff after all and still
this Bishop is not helping in the
defense there yeah that was probably bad
back here yeah this is this is really
not the best move at all what is it that
I should do 93 computer still things
black and defend with Bishop tifo yeah
well this is chess for you it's such a
funny game sometimes Bishop t1 they are
you five hang so if i take here check
this is nothing cool really cool so what
should i do 92 is winning okay it really
wins now yeah with this double attack
Queenie 496 you can just check but here
i can go King f1 and I'm not in any
problem because this is not hanging with
check and this was the big problem by
the way this is still a funny line check
check and this Shack and it's it's just
everything is just about protection
check this is what the computer gives
funny and wins yeah but this now all of
a sudden God's got really really murky I
took two minutes here I really was
totally totally irritated so the
computer just castles in this position
and since white is better a little bit
at least yeah maybe Emily I was totally
unnerved him here here and this is equal
just yeah well at least it's equal after
the shock yeah but this is a mistake
right and should be a mistake yeah at
young I'm much better he can fight
though computer wants to do this and
doesn't give that as completely clear
because of this line that's funny here
thanks check check check and here that
is indeed not easy huh what should
probably win but well I'm running out of
material running out of pawn see a
little bit yeah crazy at the way it went
it was really just a winner so that was
a bit lucky after this disaster is
opening and I mean after well he had yet
he should lose here simply or get into
big trouble but then then I got myself
into trouble with Bishop t2 which looks
totally normal but I didn't really
calculate their queen d force the only
move that that makes any kind of sense
okay well thanks for watching